[Musik]
es ist das alte Polen das hier
demonstriert die abgewählte
Regierungspartei peace und ihre Anhänger
verkraften den Machtverlust nicht
Warschau letzten Donnerstag ein paar
zehntausende ihr Motto Protest der
freien Polen bizarr war es doch
katinskis peace die Polen komplett einer
Partei unterordnen
wollte jeder Pole der sein Heimatland im
Herzen hat sollte hier sein und
teilnehmen
die neuen haben uns die Medien genommen
das Fernsehen sie sind wie Banditen
reingegangen peacewähler verschreckt den
Polen dreht sich derzeit um
180° von internationalen Beobachtern
längst gefordert Ministerpräsident
Donald Tusk und seine linksliberale
Koalition sind angetreten um zu
demokratischen europäischen Werten
zurückzukehren der Präsident hat seit
2015 seinen Anteil an der Zerstörung der
Rechtsstaatlichkeit und der
Rechtsordnung in Polen Präsident duda
sein Gegenspieler PE treu und ihre
letzte Bastion gegen TuS Liberalen
Weg wir haben es heute mit dem Terror
der sogenannten Rechtsstaatlichkeit zu
tun sogenannte Rechtsstaatlichkeit als
Terror auch das PIZ höflich die Gesten
knallhart der Machtkampf am Tag an dem
TuS Ministerpräsident wird ist klar duda
die Marionette der Nationalkonservativen
tut alles um TuS das lebenens schwer zu
machen
kann jedes Gesetz per Veto blockieren
Tusk aber will Medien und Justiz wieder
entpolitisieren bei Betrachtern auch aus
anderen Ländern kann der Eindruck
entstehen dass es erst eine Regierung
gab jetzt eine andere und diese einige
harte brutale Maßnahmen ergreift darum
geht es nicht bei dem Wandel in Polen a
Jahre lang wurde versucht das politische
System zu ändern sogar einen
zivilisatorischen Wandel
herbeizuführen wir sind imentlich
rechtlichen Rundfunk verabredet TVP 8
Jahre lang im Klammergriff der
peacepropaganda der Wandel hat hier
schon Einzug gehalten per
Parlamentsbeschluss der neuen
tuskregierung zur Wiederherstellung der
Unparteilichkeit die Führungsriege wurde
ausgetauscht auch Redakteure sie wollen
jetzt unabhängig
berichten wir wollen den Polen zeigen
dass man unterschiedlicher Meinung sein
kann aber dass man sich nicht hassen
muss das heißt wenn wir auch politische
Gruppen
die ener Polen
politikertischen Parteien
im so sah es Jahre lang aus die
proeutsche Mission von Tusk steht da ein
Dauerthema TuS jahrelang als angeblicher
Befehlsempfänger der deutschen
verunglimpft beim alten
TVP es gibt eine ABM zschen TuS und den
deutschen
dieutchenenierminister
zuerden
umente den
migrap jetzt gelten wieder die Standards
des öffentlichrechtlichen Fernsehens
Redaktionsleiter PAV puska kommt vom
unabhängigen privattv die alten TVP
Leute waren eher Aktivisten als
Journalisten die Einseitigkeit des alten
tvps war auch von OSZE Wahlbeobachtern
in den letzten Jahren bemängelt worden
das hier sind alles Leute die neu sind
die diese Sprache nicht benutzt haben
ich kann doch den Leuten nicht sagen
dass sie hier ein neues Fernsehen haben
aber mit den alten
Reportern wochenlang tobte der
Machtkampf um TVP peace Leute versuchen
im Dezember den Sender zu besetzen allen
voran parteisf katinski er übernachteet
demonstrativ im Foyer will sein
Spielzeug sein Propagandainstrument
nicht hergeben diesen Kampf hat er
verloren Redaktionssitzung gestern
Morgen zeitgleich erreicht eine
Inszenierung der peace einen
iter im die Ehefrauen von zwei
rechtmäßig verhafteten peaceepitikern
beklatscht von der peace gebt unsere
Abgeordneten frei skandiert die
peacefraktion die Plätze der
Verurteilten symbolisch mit Plakaten
besetzt passend zum opfernarrativ auf
dem Präsidentenpalast eine Projektion
der Verhafteten die an das ikonische
Bild des solidarnos Freiheitskampfes
erinnert
aus Leuten die rechtskräftig verurteilt
sind Helden zu machen nicht wegen ihrer
politischen Ttigkeit sondern wegen
schwerer Verstöße gegen das Gesetz als
Staatsbeamte das ist etwas das die Würde
des Staates
untergräbt K osabiawag pastwa
diehaung den die aus dem
Präsidentenpalast als die Verhaftung
Anstand hatte dud höchst persönlich den
Ex Minister und dessen exstaatssekretär
zu sich geholt hoffte offenbar sie
schützen zu können verurteilte Politiker
als
palastgäste beide wurden letzten
Dezember wegen Amtsmissbrauchs zu zwei
Jahren Haft verurteilt sie hatten einen
politischen Rivalen in inszenierte
Korruptionsverfahren verwickelt im Jahr
2007 doch peace parteichf katinski
versucht die Verhaftung als Racheaktion
der neuen Regierung zu verkaufen
in der na eilen er und ein paar ihm
Treue zur Polizeistation und später
weiter vors
Gefängnis wir haben die ersten
politischen Gefangenen seit
1989 das ist sehr
traurig seine Anhänger glauben ihm das
und Tusk die rote Krähe steht da wird
uns nicht besiegen eine peacepitikerin
postet Tusk der wie Putin und
Lukaschenko politischer Gefangene nimmt
das ist eine Gerichtsentscheidung
Polizeiarbeit da ist kein Platz für
Politik ich bin besorgt dass Präsident
duda in Aktionen verwickelt ist die von
Kinski organisiert werden dem peace
Parteichef und seinen
Leuten die Störfeuer der peace werden
bleiben gestern Abend vor dem Gefängnis
des Verhafteten
exinnenministers katholische Hymnen für
einen Verurteilten eine Eskalation aber
dürfte ausbleiben die Mehrheit der
Gesellschaft hat sich im Herbst
entschieden für ein liberaleres Polen
auch wenn im Präsidentenpalast bis
2025 noch das alte Polen an der Macht
klebt